david mueller speaks out after taylor
swift wins lawsuit i didn't do it i
never grabbed her on monday a jury found
the radio DJ liable of assault and
battery for allegedly groping the shake
it off singer during a meet and greet in
denver colorado in 2013 Mueller who has
denied the claims filed a three million
dollar suit against the singer in
September 2015
claiming she cost him his job and future
career opportunities the twenty
seven-year-old countersued Mueller for
$1 accusing him of assault and battery
in his first sit-down TV interview since
the jury's ruling which aired in part on
Tuesday's Good Morning America Mueller
reacted to the photo that was presented
in court that Swift claims was taken at
the time she was allegedly groped by him
that wasn't ready I wasn't invited to be
in the photo so it was I just moved into
the shot the best I could and he was
asked if he was wanting people to
consider that Swift is lying or at least
mistaken what I'm saying is that I
didn't do what they say I did I didn't
do it I never grabbed her I never had my
hand under her skirt and I can pass a
polygraph meanwhile the Grammy winner is
pleased with the jury's ruling on Monday
she issued a statement saying she plans
to help other victims quote I will be
making donations in the near future to
multiple organizations that help sexual
assault victims defend themselves
[Music]